a bill can you prove beyond a reasonable
doubt that the earth is a sphere and not
flat because I have a lot of Facebook
friends who say that it's fact and I
just can't convince them thank you is
the earth flat or round it's round
okay now let's see how do we go about
proving that go to the seashore go to a
seashore and figure out why you can't if
you live on the east coast figure out
why you can't see Spain from the east
coast of North America it looks like you
might have a st. Louis hat on I'm not
sure just go up to the middle of the
Mississippi River and look south why
can't you see the Louisiana why can't
you see New Orleans what's what's the
problem there oh and then climb a tower
or go to the top of a hill or a mountain
and you'll see a little farther but you
will not see to the other side of the
earth places we know to exist for
example I've been to London I can tell
you other people have I've been to
Vancouver British Columbia and you
cannot see Vancouver British Columbia
from from Boise Idaho let alone from New
York City or Toronto or what have you
just start there then if you're if you'd
like look at pictures from space where
you see the earth as a sphere those
pictures are not faked and I'll tell you
just if nothing else here's why you can
tell they're not faked just to create
the paperwork that nASA has created for
in NASA in this one case just the
paperwork to send anything out in space
to send people into orbit or to send
them to the moon that amount of
paperwork would make faking it
prohibitively expensive no one could
afford to generate that much that much
documentation and the other thing if you
want to get into this if you're really
serious are really serious have them get
on a boat or a ship and go out at sea
and you'll notice you can't see
infinitely far furthermore if you get
into it enough pick up a book about
navigation or go online and learn about
navigation a very very important thing
you have to take to account when you try
to navigate the ocean from a ship or a
boat is how high you are off the sea
surface the higher you are off the sea
surface the farther you can see the
farther away the horizon is oh my now
this discovery that the world is round
was made I'm Nessen 15 it was published
in 1540 now I'm concerned was Copernicus
I'm concerned it might have been fifteen
thirty but it was about them it was in
the sixteenth century that the earth was
shown to be a ball but it was known to
be a ball by a lot of other people
before Copernicus in the Western world
what we now call the Western world
Western Hemisphere
the ancient Greeks noticed that from
time to time the earth casts a shadow on
the moon this is a lunar eclipse where
the moon gets in the shadow of the earth
the sunlight is being blocked by the
earth and moons on the far side of the
earth and that shadow is always curbed
in the only shape that only that always
produces a curve no matter what the
orientation that is to say whether
you're standing in Greece at night or if
you're standing then 12 hours later in
buenos aires at night the curve the the
shadow is always curved so the ancient
Greeks knew that the earth was a ball
they didn't know to the degree of the
size of it to the degree of precision we
know now and you guys come on everybody
watches newscast you all use mobile
phones you all see airplanes fly around
you all go to see Ed Sheeran in concert
one day in London another day in
Melbourne Australia this all depends of
our fundamental idea understanding of
the size of the earth and its shape with
extraordinary precision and if you want
to get into it the earth isn't quite a
sphere it's a little it's spin is little
booth stretched it made it slightly
oblate as the saying goes this is all
susceptible to analysis but spend some
time it's learning about navigation tell
your friends to spend some time learning
about navigation navigations change the
world by the way what are you wearing
you're wearing stuff that came from
another part of the world on a ship it
didn't get here by magic it got here
through science